[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est ce couple de danseurs inquiète une
gravure dans le style de durrer mais là
vous allez totalement libre - je vous
rappelle un travail d'interprétation
ce qui serait bien c'est de réaliser ce
panneau qui est relativement petit ennui
pièce huit pièces de verre
donc vous avez la journée ce qui est
très court généralement un vitrail ça se
réalise en une semaine
top chrono c'est parti
[Musique]
sam a très rapidement fait penser à un
guitariste vous voyez la position du
danseur qui tient une guitare comme un
rockeur est la position de la danseuse
bretonne moi aussi je vais penser à une
femme une chanteuse qui tient un micro
sur scène donc je vais essayer
je vais essayer d'intégrer l'instrument
de musique et une micro dans le dessin
l'interprétation d'une gravure en
vitrail et c'est plutôt compliqué et en
général l'on est bien l'exercice de le
faire sur une journée c'est vraiment un
difficile en venir et vu que c'est une
danse de paysans moi je me dis que ça
peut aussi se passer en france donc pour
le fond je fais prendre
la couleur bleu blanc rouge que tu monde
connaît qui est intéressant c'est avec
les acquis fin du moyen-âge passé à
l'image d'une gravure une toute autre
époque et essayer de traduire la chose
avec les moyens de n'est pas que les
anciens on a coupé des gabarits à la
dimension du morceau de verre que les
vestiaires on la pose sur la plaque de
verre et la foule
[Musique]
c'est la poudre de plomb et la poudre de
verre elle peut avoir plusieurs teintes
marron noir
la concurrence elle est marron foncé
pour la pour la fixer faut passer la
pièce d'ouvert au four ça ce pas très
compréhensible ce qui se passe dans
tintin nos intérêts à ces années sombres
à la et faire venir son épée vraiment au
premier plan
[Musique]
je
dernière étape c'est ce qu'on appelle la
mise en plan donc du coup c'est de
sortir les différents morceaux de verre
avec ses baguettes de points s'ils ont
des profils de plus l'on empêche alors
ses tableaux je les appelais
la liesse populaire dans le thème
modernes anciens
je les appelais caricature est il là
c'est plus ou moins inspirés du style de
tomi ungerer qui est un illustrateur
strasbourgeois
j'ai décidé de l'appeler fest noz un
rapport avec les fêtes les festivals
bretons notamment les vielles charrues
j'ai décidé de le traiter comme une
affiche donc j'ai intégré les bretons
savent si bien danser venez le voir à
carhaix